All right.
Kiwoba Allaire, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm very excited to be here.
Thank you for having me.
Quite honored.
This is going to be a wonderful journey
that you'll take me through
over these next 20 minutes.
I'm excited to hear
about your personal journey.
I'm very excited to hear about
the organization that you've founded
and just the whole process
of both being a tech executive
but also owning this organization
and being so passionate
about empowering the missions
that you're off to.
So, I don't want to give too much away.
Please take it away.
GIRL STEM STARS, tell me about this.
Oh, sure.
Thank you so much again for having me.
My name is Kiwoba Allaire.
I am the CEO and founder
of GIRL STEM STARS.
We advance girls of color
from underrepresented communities in STEM,
science, technology, engineering and math.
A lot of people ask me,
"Why did you start GIRL STEM STARS?"
the whole entrepreneurial story.
And it's actually very organic.
I started doing this type of work
at a tech company years ago
where I was bringing in girls of color
every Wednesday.
We had about a busload of 50 girls
that would come in,
and each department in the tech company
would teach the girls something,
and then we'd bus them back.
From there, I noticed that
we didn't have a lot of black girls.
We had Latina, we had Pan-Asian,
we had a lot of girls,
but I maybe had one or two black girls.
And so, as things happen, I wound up
having a near-death experience.
And in 2013, I was supposed to have
a routine surgery
that actually went sideways.
I wound up septic all over my body.
It particularly hit my heart,
my lungs, my kidneys,
and what else, my heart, my lungs,
my kidneys and something else,
but at the end of the day,
I was in a coma for three weeks.
And it's interesting,
my doctors tell me that-
Three weeks?
Yes.
So, when I came out of that coma,
I had no idea what happened.
I thought I got hit by a car.
And my family had to explain to me
that I was very sick
and that I nearly died.
My doctor said I was
five minutes from death three times.
And long story short,
it was a long recovery,
but my Auntie ...
came to my recovery bed and she said,
"Girl, do you realize that God sent
his ... and ministering angels
to fight for you and to keep you?
And it's not just because you have,
it's not just to continue working
at that tech company,
you have a greater purpose on your life."
And I realized,
let me pray about this,
let me think about this,
but at the end of the day,
I started to think what bugs me?
What am I not happy about
in this world?
And I remember I used to
complain and whine to recruiters
and HR people saying,
"Hey, Susie with the blond hair
and the blue eyes, hire more people
that look like me."
Because I was the only person
that looked like me at most tech companies
that I worked at.
I didn't get to see anybody
that looked like myself on a daily basis,
and that can tend to bug you
after a while.
So yeah, I realized okay,
stop whining and complaining,
let's be the change that I wanted to see.
Wait wait, just before we get to this change,
because I don't get to meet many people
who have gone through
such an extraordinary experience,
a horrible experience,
but extraordinary nevertheless,
of being in a coma for three weeks,
waking up.
Give me a little bit of context as to,
and paint me a picture
of what's happening there.
So, you wake up.
You're in the tech world.
There are things that bother you,
and you're going to have all this passion
and ambition to change those things,
but what do you feel?
Are you confused?
Do you understand what was happening?
Who was next to you?
Paint me that picture,
because I think it's fascinating.
So, I'm really blessed.
My husband, when I came out of it,
the nurses told me,
"Your husband was like a lion
at the front of your bed."
I'm like,
"My husband?"
Because he's actually usually
quite mild mannered,
and I was very surprised that they said
he was really fighting for me.
I mean of course
I knew he'd fight for me,
but not in the physical way
that they had expressed.
And when he, I guess,
he asked for permission
to put speakers in the ICU
so that he could play my favorite music,
which is bossa nova, Sergio Mendez.
And so when, during the coma
I could hear the music,
which is interesting.
People say,
"Can you hear anything during the coma?"
Yes, you can. At least I did.
I could hear the music.
Really? You remember hearing the music?
I knew I was in a safe place
'cause it's my music.
Nobody else that I know
listens to that music.
So, when I heard that music,
I knew that I was in a safe place.
But coming out of the coma,
it's like coming out of a cloud.
And I won't get into like
what I thought happened in there,
but it's like coming out
of a big puffy cloud,
and everything's kind of muted
but it's starting to come,
everything's starting to come awake.
And then you hear people talking
and people are encouraging you.
I remember hearing a nurse telling me,
"Come on, you can't die.
You have a lot to live for."
I remember her rubbing my arm.
I could tell the people
that came into the room
that cared about me.
I knew that if my family was there,
I didn't know who they were,
but I just felt a warm entity
that I knew I was safe
and that person cared about me
as opposed to the brush of a white jacket.
You hear a clicking of the board
where your medical stuff is on.
And then click it goes back down,
and they're gone.
It was like a cold breeze
that went through, right?
So, coming out of that,
I had no idea what happened.
What I was told is
I came out of the surgery, and I was fine.
I went home. Doctor said,
"You're up in two weeks."
And inevitably I wasn't.
And I passed out in our home.
So, my husband raced me
to the emergency room, and they told him
that my white blood cell count
was off the charts and to call family.
And so, he called all of the family.
I do remember hearing murmurs of them
talking, saying they love me,
that they're praying for me,
but I don't remember anything after that.
Supposedly, I was in recovery
for two weeks
after they did another surgery,
and I just started to crash.
I guess they said
I was talking to a nurse,
and then all of a sudden
the blue light goes on, and I crashed
and they had to revive me.
And they called my husband and said,
"We've induced your wife into a coma
so that she doesn't die,
and we don't know what's wrong with her."
So, at that point, my husband had to call
the CEO of the tech company
I was working with and say,
"Yeah, I don't think Kiwoba's
coming back."
And interestingly enough,
that CEO happened to know people
on the board of the hospital
that I was at.
And my husband, he said,
"Let me call some people"
and he wound up helping out.
And my husband said
there was a guy from Stanford
in the room,
there was four heads of surgeries
and head of this department of pulmonary.
And after a while,
they finally figured out
what was wrong with me
and proceeded to, he said like
10 IV poles showed up in the room,
and they all seemed to know
what was going on now
and they knew what to do
to get me better.
But he was told it was still
a 50-50 chance that I would survive.
Wow.
Right.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
So, you come out
of this crazy experience,
and you're taking the passion
that you had before, now, it sounds like,
with a deeper purpose and meaning
to what you can and should be doing
with your time.
And while you were doing
extraordinary things in your job,
and you still are, you chose to now devote
another portion of your time
to this new project.
Tell me about GIRL STEM STARS.
So, as I mentioned,
I was in my recovery bed
when I came to that enlightenment of
okay, stop whining and complaining,
be the change that you wanted to see.
And so, I literally called up,
I picked up the phone
from my recovery bed,
and I called LegalZoom and said,
"I want to start a non-profit
that advances black girls
and girls of color
from underserved communities in STEM."
And it started to roll out from there,
started doing the 501(c)3.
But I found that I came to,
like I was crawling up a hill,
but I just got stuck.
And I was talking to one of my friends
who's on the council of East Palo Alto,
and he's like,
"How are you doing?"
And I burst into tears, and he's like,
"What's going on?"
And I said,
"I've been trying to do
this 501(c)3."
He goes,
"Girl, you're trying to do a 501(c)3
while you're in recovery in bed?"
He says, "What are you crazy?"
So, he says,
"You need to speak up."
And that was one enlightment right there:
don't carry it all yourself,
you need help.
Every leader needs help.
And so, he put out the word
and found a lawyer that was interested
in the work that we were doing,
and I actually crawled out
of my recovery bed to go meet him.
And he's like,
"What are you doing here?
I thought we were gonna be
on the phone?"
I'm like,
"Anybody who wants to help me
with this project,
I want to see you face to face."
And at the end of the day,
he took the whole project from me,
paid for it, and worked with the IRS
to do the 501(c)3.
So, I mean, I'm a believer.
So, this is where I say,
"Look at how God works in my life."
Right?
And then, we got a lot of recognition
and participation, a lot of volunteers.
I gathered all the girls,
and we started doing events
at tech companies.
So, we would take a group of girls,
say a hundred girls over to Google.
And they would have a whole day.
I know the parents were grateful
that they get to drop off their kid
at 7:30 in the morning.
We feed them breakfast,
we give them goodie bags,
t-shirts, you name it,
and then we're teaching them,
we expose them to amazing mentors
like black women astronauts
and the VP of YouTube
who is a black woman.
The girls freaked out. They're like,
"You're the boss of Youtube?"
And she's like,
"Yes, I am."
And they're like,
"Oh, I want to be like her."
Boom, we automatically have
that child's attention,
and that girl wants to be,
'cause I usually ask them,
"Who do you want to be like
when you grow up?"
They're like,
"Oh, I want to be like Beyonce."
And,
or "I want to be a veterinarian
so I could take care of puppies.
or "I wanna be a dancer."
But at the end of the day,
when they get to meet
a woman like this,
the vice president of YouTube,
which they all relate to,
or they get to meet
a black female rocket scientist from NASA
who has braids just like them.
I remember she came up and she said,
"Guess how much I make?"
And they're like,
"I don't know, $5,000, $10,000."
She goes,
"I make over $200,000."
They're like, "What?
Okay, I want to be like you."
Automatically, after hearing
what this woman does
and how much she makes,
they're instantly attracted to,
if you will, the fame of it.
She's a new she hero for them,
a new STEM hero for them.
STEM hero, I like that.
Yes. Yes.
There's lots of instances where we
take a busload of girls to NASA,
and they get to hang out
with the Black Women Resource Group there
and eat lunch with them,
go sit by their side,
and see what they do on a daily basis.
It blows the girls mind.
Amazing.
Absolutely.
Wow. So, talk to me a little bit
about this impact because, first of all,
I'd like to understand the context
of the problem a little bit bigger,
and through that also
the opportunity for impact.
So, I'm also coming in
from outside of the country.
And obviously, 2020 has brought up
a lot of different adversities.
One thing that it has clearly brought up
is the issue of minorities
within the United States
and the fight for equality
and for diversification everywhere.
Obviously, with the work that you're doing
with GIRL STEM STARS is incredible,
and I'm sure that it's impacted
so many lives of young women.
Talk to me a little bit
about this greater scope.
So STEM, girls, and minorities,
what is happening today,
and where are you aiming for?
So, it's interesting.
You don't see girls really interested
in math and science and technology,
but when we bring them into a tech company
or at NASA,
but also now that we're, because of covid,
we're doing virtual learning,
the fact that they get to see
a woman on the screen, ask her questions,
how did you get there,
what did you do.
That mentor will show
pictures of themselves as a little girl
so the girls can resonate with them.
Like okay, she was like me at one point.
This is where I believe
all educators need to be starting
very, very young
by getting girls interested in STEM.
And it's super easy to do it in a fun way
where the girls are learning
and they're excited about it,
and they see people,
they see women, that they want to emulate,
that they want to be like.
And then at this point in the game
you're building, you can see the ambition where, again,
like the black rocket scientists from NASA,
they have that,
"If I can see it, I can be it."
And this is what we need more of
for minorities to just be exposed
to more STEM and to expose them
to more STEM heroes.
And it's a global thing.
I want to take GIRL STEM STARS global.
My first step is to take it to Africa.
Right now what I do is the videos
that you see online
of like the girls visiting Google
and Microsoft and such,
I share them
with my counterparts in Africa,
and that enables those girls out there
to be able to see, wow, this is what
I have my video guy. I'm like,
"Make it like you're walking in
and you're in it,
like you're in the experience"
so that the girls in Africa
can really feel like
this is what Google looks like,
this is what NASA looks like,
this is what
a black rocket scientist looks like.
There's some STEM heroes.
So, what has been the impact
of GIRL STEM STARS so far?
How many girls
have gone through the program,
and where do you aim it go to
in terms of the scale?
Right.
We have touched over a thousand girls.
A thousand? Wow.
Yes, since inception,
over a thousand girls in the Bay Area
and further.
I actually did a STEM camp virtually
for girls in Malaysia.
So, a friend of mine was going out there
to do an educational program
and they said,
"Would you mind doing
GIRL STEM STARS in Malaysia?"
and I'm like, "Sure."
It was amazing to see all the girls
with their headgear
and their little GIRL STEM STARS ...
and they're like, "Hey"
So I definitely, now that we're in this virtual world,
the world is my oyster,
when you think about it,
that I can take GIRL STEM STARS anywhere.
And that's interesting.
So, you're saying that
with acceleration
of the virtual collaboration interaction
due to covid, now, I mean,
'cause you could have done this before, right.
You could have said,
"Okay. I'm going to focus on
primarily virtual gatherings rather than
allocate a lot of time and resources
to going physically"
And it actually makes a lot of sense
that probably for every field trip
that's organized,
you could probably organize
five gatherings virtually, right,
for the same Kiwoba time,
for the same resources.
So it's really fascinating.
So, now you're planning
on taking this global,
allowing interaction, I'm guessing,
also from participants around the world.
And what else needs to happen
in order to level the playing field
or provide not an opportunity for them
to study STEM, because I'm guessing
that a lot of times they do,
but to get their minds curious about it
and to make it socially acceptable
for also minorities, black girls
that you're targeting, to help them
get started in the process?
More awareness needs to be
brought up in media,
because kids are always in media,
social media, and we need more STEM heroes,
and we need STEM to look cool and fun.
Right now, it's for the nerdy group
and it's not, really.
Right. It's not.
I mean, I show videos
of my husband and I scuba diving,
and we're kissing underwater
and the girls are like,
"Oh, that looks like so much fun."
And I'm like,
"Do you realize how much STEM
is on my back?
"Do you realize how many
math and science classes I had to take
before they let me jump off that boat?"
And then this is where they're like,
"Oh, STEM can be fun too."
I try to teach the girls that STEM
is in every aspect of their lives.
It's in your phone.
It's in everything that you do.
It's in the computer.
It's in everything,
and this is where they want to be,
we need them to be curious
about every subject:
math, science, technology, engineering.
And also we need companies
to invest in our youth.
They keep complaining,
"Oh well, the pipeline is dry."
No, it's not. You need to start
investing in communities,
invest in teaching,
also invest in widening their scope
of recruiting so that
they're not just looking at
the high profile HBCUs
but also city colleges and state colleges.
They want the top four Ivy.
Come on, that's not who runs the world.
All right.
If we want to be able to be successful
with our technology moving forward,
we need to include more minorities
otherwise, globally,
we will not be able to interact.
Globally, our technology will not work
if we don't invite minorities
to have a seat at the table.
So, what we're doing at GIRL STEM STARS
is we're starting them as early
as seven years old to 18 years old.
And so, this is where we're building
the future leaders,
the future entrepreneurs,
the future decision makers,
the future business owners.
And this is where we'll see change.
That's just wonderful.
And obviously, as this is a nonprofit,
if anybody happens to listen to this
and is also passionate about this cause
and would like to contribute,
I'm sure that I can make an introduction
and send off the contact
for GIRL STEM STARS.
But before we leave, Kiwoba,
I have to ask the most important question:
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Yes, and thank you
for the plug on donations,
www.girlstemstars.org
you can make a donation there.
Three words about me.
One, I'm faithful.
I am a believer, and I'm truly grateful
that God has put this calling
for GIRL STEM STARS on my life.
And it's amazing. It has changed my life.
It changes the life of every person
who ever comes and volunteers
with these girls. They're like,
Oh my gosh. I didn't realize
it was so easy to just come
and roll up my sleeves,
meet these girls,
and then at the end of an eight hour day
or if it's just a couple of hours
on a virtual, the girls are so fun
and they see the little light bulbs
going of in the girls minds.
They're like, so moved going.
"I want to do that again."
So, we're not just touching the girls,
but we're also touching
employees at different companies,
we're touching executives.
And so, this is a great calling.
It needs to happen right now.
Right now.
This is a very rich environment
for the world to be able to start
making a difference on their own.
So like, this was my situation
where I don't see black people
on a daily basis in Silicon Valley.
But what is important to somebody else?
What makes you tick?
What's important to you?
Or what bugs you?
I'm asking you.
Right. Well, for me,
it's the dissemination of information.
There are so many people like you
that are so influential
and have so many incredible experiences
that without a medium
to disseminate this information,
the majority of the population
will not be able to hear it.
And especially the stories
that I try to cover here, these are not
TechCrunch or Crunchbase stories;
these are more about the journeys.
And the reason, the passion
that you're starting GIRL STEM STARS
and this sort of epiphany that you had
and this passion that you've acquired
over the years
and the trigger from that coma,
that's exactly the things
that I'd like to share.
Right. So, you're already walking out your,
and that's my next word is passion,
you're already walking out your passion.
When I've been on stage before
as a motivational speaker,
I ask some of the people in the front row,
"So, what are you interested in?
What bugs you?"
And one woman is like,
"I love the beach."
I'm like,
"Well, get your friends together
and go clean it up."
She's like,
"Oh, my gosh, it's that easy?"
I'm like, "Yes."
Find a purpose in your life
other than just the typical job
that you do on a daily basis.
It's as simple as,
okay, the next woman,
"Okay, what are you interested in?"
"Well, I love animals.
I love dogs."
Well then go take care of some dogs.
Go to a shelter, bring your friend,
get a Facebook group going, do something,
and you'll feel better as a human being
than just crunching at your daily job
when you have a purpose, right?
- 100%
And it's so easy.
Just think about
what am I interested in,
what I don't like in this world,
and then be the change you want to see
and get out there,
grab your friends, and do it.
It's that simple.
And I don't think everybody needs
a God epiphany and have
to nearly die to be able to come
to where I've gotten to.
I'm not telling people,
you can skip all that,
I'm just telling you
it's this easy, right.
It's this easy.
And then my next one is driven.
I'm faithful, I'm passionate,
and I'm driven
as you heard from my stories.
- That definitely exudes through this whole conversation.
of trying to start a nonprofit
from my recovery bed.
100%.
Very driven.
Kiwoba, thank you very much
for the time and for the inspiration.
This was just eye opening
and just wonderful.
Thank you very, very much.
Yes.
It's been an honor to be here.
Thank you so much for
showcasing GIRL STEM STARS today
and the work that we're doing.
God bless you.
I appreciate it.
Take care.
Bye.